you
[Music]
so yeah my name is Ania Schmucker I'm a
data scientist at Cardo Cardo we work
with spatial data quite a bit we use
common data science techniques with
spatial data there's a lot of special
properties with spatial data so I wanted
to highlight some of that today
hopefully you can take it away and use
it in your workflows as well so I wanted
to start out by just giving an overview
of spatial data this is not complete by
any means there there are so many
different types of spatial data but the
ones that I want to present today are
some of the more common ones that we
experience in data science and then I
want to highlight some of the more
modern data spatial data types that come
out as data scientists I think the most
common way we see spatial data is just
as latitude longitude sometimes you
might even just have that those as
features in your in your model like the
Latin long will just be numeric features
that you want to do sometimes there's
nothing wrong with that sometimes you
can give really valuable insights the
map that we have here
it's just car crashes in Seattle the
attribute is the number of people
involved in the car crash and we're
showing it over time other types of data
that we commonly encounter our zip codes
zip codes are a particularly tricky type
of spatial data there I have some tips
on zip codes the first tip is try not to
use the zip code boundaries their zip
codes if you know anything about them
they're more similar to the routes that
mail people follow they're not polygons
at all so you can't use them as a region
or anything like that the the way that
we usually deal with zip codes is a
geography from the sense is called zcta
it's the code tabulation areas and there
are approximate SIM cards and by being
approximate and you have a lot long for
somebody they might end up in a
difference is it zcta
even though that even though it has the
same zip code number
zip codes change quite a bit with with
postal routes if new addresses are added
the rebalanced all the time and the
Postal Service doesn't have a like a
free data set of zip codes it's actually
a very proprietary data set that's very
expensive that you can purchase from
them and zip codes changed frequently so
you can't really rely on them if you
want to do any advanced analysis and
actually a lot of errors have happened
because people use zip codes for their
analysis so the one I'm highlighting
here there was an early analysis of an
epidemiology analysis of the level of
lead and people's blood they used zip
codes as a basis for their analysis
instead of a different boundary and so
that what they're doing is measuring the
blood the levels of blood for people in
Flint Michigan which is has a municipal
water source but they're using the zip
codes which you can see kind of those
blue boundaries and the Flint has it's
kind of like that filled in green
boundary and so a lot of the zip codes
area lies outside of the municipal
boundaries and so the the measurements
that they were taking we're actually
diluting the blood levels in people's
bodies and so it wasn't really seen as
as a health crisis at all but when the
analysis was to be done and it used the
proper levels and they found that that
levels were very elevated in people's
bodies another one is this is somebody
that I follow on Twitter who who works
with spatial data a lot and he was able
to identify that he had a claim that was
denied from his insurance because they
use zip code boundaries instead of his
county boundary and the zip code and you
can see that he kind of postulates that
the zip code that he's in has this
little little bit that goes outside of a
county and the the infrastructure for
the insurance company wasn't relied on
the zip codes
the county boundaries and so he was
denied this claim even though he was
within the county boundaries and so for
for the previous cases those were kind
of like accidents or people are ignorant
of how to use the boundaries people also
take advantage of moving boundaries for
political gain or for other purposes so
gerrymandering is something that's very
much in the news right now
politicians changed the boundaries that
try to dilute certain certain types of
votes so they can get more people in
Congress or or some other political body
and I think that like the really stark
thing about this you can see that the
amount of vote was about 50/50 across
the state for these congressional
boundaries but the way they were drawn
you ended up with like seventy percent
going one way and then the rest going
the other way
and there's actually one that was
undecided when this was it's just like
November 2018 that's the one that had
the the election fraud and they called
the election null and so they they're
recalling the election and so
congressional boundaries are drawn
because we have a census in the United
States this is used and a lot of spatial
analysis because like they collect a lot
of data it's pretty well-funded
you get really accurate number or
accounts for like population median
income and a lot of other measures I put
this slide up here because I think it's
really funny how the senses evolved in
terms of its outreach this is like in
1940 they put this really creepy picture
of an Uncle Sam on there and and he's
like the census taker which sounds like
a creepy way of saying it but I don't
feel like the census really personifies
itself anymore it's just kind of like
this kind of cold government agency
that's just doing statistics so the
census is a really important source of
spatial data it's it's offered at a lot
of geographical scales at the block
level which can be very small and
where you live in the country up to the
up to the country level and this is just
a an animated gif that we did at my
company just to highlight all of the
different kind of distributions of
different measures in the United States
but also we work with with census data
in the UK Spain Mexico and other
countries as well so there's tons of
information available from the Census
another sentence product is something
called loads it's it's kind of unique
the the standard census measures give
you like population within a zip code or
something like that or a county loads
gives you kind of like home to work
commute patterns and so to identify the
census track where you live and the
census tract where you work and so so
you have origin destination information
for it because it has origin and
destination it's essentially two
different geographies and you can you
can infer like like commute patterns
within a city you can see that there's a
lot of like commuting people that report
commuting from like the east coast to
the west coast or like up in Seattle
down all the way to Florida so the the
patterns that you can find in this data
are really rich and I encourage you to
look at this data set if you haven't
already seen it so those are kind of
more traditional spatial data sets some
of the more modern ones that we see and
are bit more controversial or mobility
data sets so a lot of our phones are
tracking us all the time
we have some control over it but there's
a lot of it's like lost in the terms and
conditions of it and what most of us
want the convenience instead of the
privacy aspect of it and so we're
contributing to this giant collection of
data that's tracking people all across
the world and there are a lot of
companies they aggregate this data and
then resell it as a data product and so
we are all being used as a product
essentially
for these companies the data is really
cool it's really creepy too
there's a lot of laws that have come out
across the world to kind of restrict a
lot of this but it's still kind of Wild
West days in the United States and there
are a lot of providers that offer this
data we use it at my company to some
extent we don't we don't like track
individuals we're more interested in
like foot traffic in a and very
anonymized way so you can see one way
we'll use it here this is 70 meter by 70
meter grid of Manhattan the darker the
purple the more people are within that
area so you can see how New York kind of
like breathes through or how people move
around New York through the day you can
see some of the subway lines popping up
you can see around 7:00 a.m. like right
now where the city kind of comes alive
and then you can see I don't know see
movement within within the city and this
data is really exciting in a lot of ways
because you can get these kind of like
time slices of what the population in an
area is at different times of the day
and that's something that the census
doesn't provide it kind of senses
provides information about where people
kind of like sleep at night
the mobility data provides that but also
like where do people get lunch at noon
or are it kind of any any kind of
question like that and since there's a
time series data you can make a lot of
inferences about like travel modes and
how long somebody stays in an area so
it's a pretty amazing data set there are
tons of privacy downsides to it but it's
a very prevalent type of data set with
spatial spatial and time components in
it another one this talking about tweets
as a data source feels kind of like old
school to me this map was made about
five years ago and what I love about it
is you can like you can view humans as
kind of like a sensor who are like we're
always perceiving our world and we're
reporting that information to a
centralized server somewhere so so in
the case of Twitter
these are tweets that mentioned the word
sunrise and you can see when the Sun
hits the East Coast there's this kind of
like wave of information that's sent to
the servers and you can and you can
visualize that I think this is a really
cool map because it just it shows that
like we're all kind of in this together
and reporting on very similar phenomenon
and you can aggregate it up and get
interesting things out of it
GPS data mobility is not always GPS data
the more precise mobility data you get
from your phones tends to be GPS but you
can just have peer GPS devices this is a
totally non creepy version it's a house
cat and suburban Massachusetts that
somebody put a GPS tracker on it's open
data on a website called move bank org
so if you're ever looking for good GPS
data of animals move Bank is a really
good source in New York City Taxi data
used to have flatted longitude for
pickups and drop-offs but people found
out they can stalk people and buildings
and other creepy things for that so the
newer open taxi data from New York City
is has like fairly large geographies so
you can't you can't track people on them
this map is from a workshop I gave a
couple years ago where I wanted to see
if I could figure out people's movement
around like different buildings within
within New York City and the really
creepy thing about these old taxi
datasets is you can so if you say like
you want a building like the Goldman
Sachs building or something like that
you can drop the point draw a buffer of
maybe you like 100 meters around that
point and for any drop off or pick up
that happened within there you can
backtrack and then find maybe an airport
that they went to and then since the
data has a time component as well you
can figure out maybe when they got off
their airplane maybe like 20 30 minutes
before that
and then the the GPS data so precise in
you know where on the sidewalk they were
picked up and so you can even guess like
which terminal you can know which
terminal and like which
they came out of so again a lot of
really big privacy downsides to the
spatial data and something and I think
it's really important to think about
from the ethic ethical side of being a
data scientist there's there's just a
lot of stories in this data and it's
really important to protect privacy of
the people behind it you can get country
scale data this is another mobility data
set but what I love about this one is
one thing I do really love about
mobility data is it can help you with
Regional Planning so if you're trying to
figure out how to optimize road networks
so so that there may be safer or or you
know you want to figure out like how
many people are going through them at
certain times you can use the mobility
data as a sample of the number of cars
they go through an area besides that I
think this is just another cool map that
shows kind of the United States kind of
like coming to life driving on the roads
and then going to sleep again you can
also use it for urban planning this this
was an analysis done by my colleague
Juan Fay who's an urban planner and
she's really interested in how people
are using the built environment around
them and specifically Central Park and
so this shows how people are using
Central Park at different hours of the
day on the right hand side it's
aggregated data on the left hand side
it's by the minute so all of that just
kind of like data that has a geography
associated with it but the geographies
themself also have spatial information
I'm gonna I just kind of want to tease
this because I'm going to be using this
a little bit later but the idea of like
what is near to you what your contiguous
with can turn out to be something really
advantageous for building into your
machine learning models so I'm going to
transition a little bit to highlight a
project that we did recently on working
working with missing geospatial data so
missing data is a pretty common problem
there are a lot of different ways to
deal with it
kind of like imputing impeding the
missing valley
with the mean works if you have a small
number of missing values but then if you
have larger number of missing values you
end up ruining the distribution of your
data or making kind of false assumptions
about it
on the on the right hand side there's
all the features that we're gonna have
in our model I'll talk about them a
little bit later the problem statement
that we essentially had was if we're
giving locations for for a place like we
work in New York City we wanted to it's
like a site planning problem so we
wanted to figure out where in LA should
we build locations given that the ones
in New York were successful and we know
certain attributes about those so what
data do we have we have the locations or
we work in in New York we have the
locations for we work in Los Angeles we
have demographics that we can get from
the census there's a lot of financial
data out there MasterCard has one called
the retail location index that has a lot
of different variants that we can use
for second index for like the number of
transactions in an area the total spend
in their area and other things like that
and another one that proved useful is
points of interest so points of interest
can be like an ATM it can be a
restaurant it can be a doctor's office
it can be a fountain in a park anything
that there's like a point on a map like
when you look at Google Maps would be a
point of interest there are a lot of
different ways to define points of
interest it could be like where
somebody's spending money where
somebody's spending some time or it
could just be like a physical object
that's there and we found that these
were very useful so if there's a lot of
hotels in a region or if there's very
few education or tons of restaurants or
a lot of entertainment or something like
that that was really important for for
our model so what we're trying to do is
it's kind of like we want to find
similar areas in Los Angeles to the
areas that were in New York based off of
the the data that we're putting into our
model is essentially just finding like
the closest points in our parameter
space
and then ranking them and then like
listing like the top ten or however many
that we're interested in and building
but we had some problems some of these
are very common problems the data has
different variances and scales that's
not a problem we just we just
standardized the data some of the data
is correlated I'll talk about that in a
second we dealt with it and then we had
a lot of missing values in a lot of
areas we didn't want to just drop those
rows because it would be taken out of
consideration a lot of areas that could
be really useful and so we wanted to
fill them in but we didn't want to just
fill in the missing values with the mean
because the variation was too big so
what we did to kind of to break up the
area within Los Angeles we got we got a
Los Angeles County plus a bit more and
we broke it into a grid and called a
quadtree grid a quadtree is breaking the
world into four parts like four parts
equally in each of those parts are
broken into four more parts and each of
the sub parts are broken into four more
parts and so on and it's a hierarchical
way of breaking up the earth or any any
physical space and it allows you to do
like geospatial aggregation just on like
the length of a string and and and
unique unique quad keys but for for
smaller geographies you end up with
essentially a square grid like this and
we aggregated all of the data to that
and this is just total population in the
Los Angeles area and then the idea was
to just use principal component analysis
so we wanted to just transform our data
into set of orthogonal axes and the
reason we wanted to do this well there
are a lot of reasons it reduces the
dimensionality of the problem which is
good and so we would not
as a job drops the taxes that didn't add
a lot to the variance of the problem and
since it's a North agonal transformation
or since the axes are orthogonal even
linearly are features that were
correlated in the PCA space they were
orthogonal to each other and so it took
care of the problem with correlation but
the problem that we had is it doesn't
work if the data is missing and so
there's a technique for PCA from for
dealing with missing data
it's called probabilistic PCA so PCA
doesn't work if you have missing data
but this this algorithm recreates the
distribution of your data and helps
reconstruct the data in the PCA space
and then it gives you the principal axes
that you need from that and then once
you have once you have your principal
axes you can do that distance
calculation to figure out how close any
two geographies are or in the parameter
space and then you can get your rankings
for areas that are similar in LA to the
ones in New York and the results are
here the the squares are the are the
areas of interest that were very similar
to the ones that we had in New York and
then the the blue or the kind of purple
dots or the the existing we work
locations in LA and you can see that
some of them we hit pretty well for Thea
that for the existing locations and then
it also gives some predictions for new
locations in LA that that would be
potential according to this model anyway
potentially good locations for where we
work okay so when I was talking about
spatial data before I kind of teased
that beyond just the attributes within
the geographies you can also take
advantage of geographies around you to
kind of understand a larger
context of what's happening and so you
want to take something that's kind of
special about spatial data is you have
the context of what's around you so I've
had a good way to to make this point was
on the right hand side is a map of
unemployment within the in the United
States if you can see on the legend that
the yellower values they're lower
unemployment and then the darker purple
values are higher unemployment you can
see there's some regional patterns to
this you can see Colorado it's generally
kind of yellow but directly south of
that in New Mexico you can see there's
really high unemployment rates there's
some states that have very high
unemployment and very low unemployment
there's some states where it's very
homogeneous you can see in the
Appalachian Mountains there's like the
Rust Belt area there's a very high
unemployment but on the East Coast
especially at by New Hampshire there's a
dark region of low unemployment so
there's a lot of geographical a lot of
geographical patterns in this data and
then upper left-hand side is just a
histogram of the of the unemployment
rate and so when we're building models
typically we would just have the
unemployment rate as the feature but
we're ignoring a lot of the spatial
structure in that so if you're a county
that has low unemployment rate is it
important to know that the counties
around you have really high unemployment
rate and if that were the case maybe
there's something special about your
county that has the low unemployment and
so what I did is if you randomly move
the unemployment just like kind of like
shake up the United States to move the
unemployment around you get a map that
looks like that and would you say that
you lost any information from the first
map to this map so you can see it looks
a lot more random to it and it's in this
one knowing knowing what's going on with
your neighbors probably is something
that could help you
make some inferences maybe it's maybe
it's not very helpful but all of that
data is therefore free to grab um and
and to add to your model and the way to
extract it is there's the concept of
something called spatial weights there's
a lot of ways that you can build up
spatial weights but it's it's
essentially saying what what do you
consider a neighbor so is a neighbor
some geography that also touches you
so like neighboring counties only touch
you
does it County that only shares one
vertex is that still a neighbor our
counties within 100 miles neighbors or
10 miles or are like the five closest
counties your neighbors so there's
different ways to define it every
problem is different and how you define
a neighbor sometimes distance-based ones
are really important if your geographies
don't touch so just north of San
Francisco San Mateo County they don't
physically touch the bay the interest of
the bay gets in the way and so if you're
working with a problem where the
geographies don't touch sometimes it
makes sense to do more distance based
ones or aquella and based ones if you
have really high quality data and like
the census where all of the geographies
like very snap very nicely together
doing contiguity based ones make more
sense this is in Manhattan which has a
pretty nice grid for census data the one
in the center is just like your
geography that you're going to look at
right now and a first order neighbor
would be ones that either share a vertex
or an edge together and this is a
contiguity based wait so a first order
ones would be the ones in green the
second order ones would be the ones in
purple and then like higher higher order
neighbors would be the things in blue
you can see that for for like the
smaller geographies it kind of makes
sense that you would have a neighbor but
you can see that Central Park is that
really big census block up there and
so we're a lot of this data or a lot of
these geographies and around like 59th
Street in Manhattan but but Central Park
goes all the way to hundred and tenth
Street and so when you're doing problems
you have to like ask questions like does
it make sense to break up Central Park
into like a smaller region or just
totally get rid of it because the
population is zero in the census there's
still a lot of ambiguity when you talk
about neighbors like this and so so
related to this idea of neighbors or
spatial weights there's a really
important statistics in geospatial data
science called Moran's I it's it's an
analog of autocorrelation so
autocorrelation is if you have a time
signal you shift that time signal signal
by a delay and then you compare the
delayed signal to the original signal
and look at how correlated they are and
so if you have it like a nice sinusoidal
wave and you shift it by the wavelength
you're gonna get like perfectly Auto
correlated the analog for that and in
spatial is your your lag is a physical
distance from you and so or your lag
would be like your neighbors or
something like that so you're you're
doing that that delay shift
I'm spatially which would be like a
distance that your neighbors are from
you and it's a really cool statistic
because it helps you identify clusters
in your data so thinking about the
amount of employment data we saw that
there was some very large clusters of
low unemployment very very large
clusters of of high unemployment and we
saw some areas that were kind of quirky
that had very low unemployment but
they're surrounded by areas they had
very high unemployment and those would
be called spatial outliers and the
statistic helps you identify these areas
that could be like the areas that are
very interesting in your analysis and
you can also get p-values for for for
these and you can find regions where the
the spatial patterns there are are not
significant at all there's a lot of like
random random distribution to it similar
to what we
see for that second map that I showed
you with all the the values that were
all jumbled and a good way to kind of
like look at this statistic if you have
something like a checkerboard and you
can see your neighbors anything that
touches an on an edge you can see like
the purple or blue ones are only
touching white ones and so if the purple
is a one and the white is a zero and you
always touch something that's opposite
you're always going to be
anti-correlated with each other and so
you're gonna have a perfectly
anti-correlated autocorrelation there
and so your your value in this case
would be negative negative one and I
forgot to say that in spatial
autocorrelation the values go from
negative one to one there a couple of
other examples there the one in the
middle shows like totally random spatial
autocorrelation there's a local version
of spatial autocorrelation that helps
you find areas that are the clusters or
areas that are some of those outliers
and then the gray areas or the non
significant areas that have that that
are what you would expect if everything
was randomly distributed and one really
important way that you can use this
statistic is after you train your model
and you calculate the residuals if your
model performs really well you would
expect that the error term would be
Gaussian um have a Gaussian distribution
but if you're if you have a spatial
component to it you would also hope that
the residuals would be randomly
distributed across your map because if
you had any areas that had similar
values that are close to each other
you'd be finding clusters of some
spatial pattern the ER model is not
accounting for and so if you're using
the Moran's I statistic and you get a
value really close to zero
that means that you accounted for the
spatial patterns in your data but if you
find areas that are a lot of like high
values close to each other that that
indicates that there's
spatial process that your that your
model did not capture and I think that's
it Thanks
so I've I know that the surface of the
earth is non-euclidean something like
that and that you were talking about
missing data or is the software stack
for beginning this kind of data science
this geospatial data science is it is it
a good software stack I reuse everything
from psyche at loan and I'm ready to go
or do we need special tools to handle
this
yeah that's a great point um depending
on whether you do Python or R in Python
there's a pack Python package called
pycelle py s al Python for spatial
analytics that that does a lot of these
calculations for you it's built it fits
like it plugs in really nicely to tools
like scikit-learn it it likes data
frames and things like that but it has
the spatial back-end to ask those
spatial questions off of it and there's
similar tools for our but I don't I
don't like our No
[Music]